Hello students. Welcome
to Pharmacokinetics.
We will be
talking about the
properties of
absorption, distribution,
metabolism, and
excretion. In this first
part, it will just
be absorption and
distribution. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd
like a pharmacology chat.
Recall the pharmacokinetics
pharmacodynamics
relationship. The drug
gets into the body,
gets distributed, goes
to the pharmacologic
site of action, produces
its effect, whether
it's a therapeutic
effect or an adverse
effect. There is some
sort of a clinical
response And that could
be effectiveness, the
goal, or toxicity,
something to be minimized.
The processes of
pharmacokinetics are
absorption, indicated here
by input, distribution,
and elimination. So
elimination would be
biotransformation, in
other words, metabolism
to an inactive
metabolite or excreted.
The key factor?
Concentration. The
concentration in the
plasma will determine
the concentration at
the site of action and
that will determine
the magnitude of the
pharmacologic effect.
So,
how important really
is pharmacokinetics?
It is the pharmacokinetic
properties of
drugs that influence
efficacy and safety.
The goal of therapy
is to increase the
probability of therapeutic
success, and this
is going to depend
on the dose and
certain other factors,
and to reduce the
occurrence of adverse
effects in the body.
Sometimes we can't
stop them, but we can
at least minimize them
and mitigate them.
Here are the
learning objectives,
and it's all related to
mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms.
Please read these over.
You don't need me
to read them to you.
Preparation materials.
The only thing
that I require
is the practice
questions.
These are case vignettes
and thought problems.
I will help you
to apply the basic
concepts of pharmacology
through practice
questions. And when you
receive the answers,
then you will
see the thought
processes and
this will help you
to really learn
pharmacology.
Here are some
resources if you
choose to use them.
I provided the
links. They are
all available.
These textbook
resources are all
available in our
medical library.
I've provided
some hints to help
you to actually
master a topic
to avoid the
illusion of knowing.
You may find them
helpful as you go
through this difficult
material. The material
itself isn't
difficult, it's just
that you get so much
of it all at once.
And here are some tips.
I really would like
you to try them out.
Rephrase the main
ideas in your own
words. It's about
your own words.
You can make a
question out of them.
That helps you
think about it.
Relate the ideas
to what you
already know and
that will help
make it stick
in your brain.
And here are
some techniques.
The definitions
are here to help
you with the language
of pharmacology,
the language of medicine.
More terms.
I've provided this
overview of really
of what you need to
know and understand.
So you can focus
on these concepts
and that will answer
your question of
what do I need to
know for the test.
And I have several slides
of concepts for you.
So let us begin.
The basic idea is
a drug is given at
some particular dose.
And how do we know
what dose to give?
We look it up in the
drug monograph and
that will guide us.
But we still have to
remember about our
individual patient and
there may need to be
adjustments of the doses
that are recommended.
In the case of oral
drugs especially, they
have to be liberated
out of their tablet or
capsule or whatever
form they're going in.
And then the drug
itself must be absorbed.
If we're giving
it by intravenous
administration, it's just
going straight
into the vein.
An oral drug needs to
pass through the liver
and then it will
go to the central
compartment, and that
is the bloodstream
and the highly
perfused organs.
If it is an IV
drug, it just goes
straight into the
central compartment.
Once there, the free
drug will then move
to the site of
action, move to be
stuck on tissue
macromolecules, they call
that tissue
reservoirs, can move to
areas that are not the
therapeutic target,
but rather produce
adverse effects.
Notice these
two-way arrows.
The drug will move in and
out, in and
out, in and out.
the drug can be bound
to plasma proteins
and if it's bound to
plasma proteins it will
be riding around on
the protein bus in
the bloodstream and it
will not move to the
site of action until
it gets off the bus.
It can bind to the same
idea of these inert
molecules in the tissues,
the same concept.
Even an IV drug or
anything that bypasses
the liver first and
goes to the central
compartment will
certainly pass through the
liver where it will
undergo metabolism.
And then the
metabolites, and that can
include a metabolite
that's actually
active, toxic or
inactive, will move into
the central compartment
again from the
liver where it will
go to be excreted,
but it may also be
excreted straight
out of the liver to
the biliary system.
So that's another
route of excretion.
So this very simple
figure really
sums up absorption,
distribution,
metabolism, and
excretion, and
how all are related
to each other.
A drug must withstand
digestive fluids
and enzymes. We're
talking about drugs
that are swallowed
into the GI tract and
the digestive fluids
and enzymes are in
the stomach. The drug
must move into the
intestine where it
will be absorbed and
once it's absorbed
it has and once it's
the intestine it has
to be able to cross
the physiologic
barriers to be absorbed
and to be distributed
to the site of action.
The drug must be
able to exit the
site of action
after providing
the specific
therapeutic effect
and it must be
eliminated either by
metabolism to inactive
metabolites which is
certainly the most
common, or it actually
may be metabolized to
an active metabolite
or a toxic metabolite.
In any case,
if it's metabolized to
an active metabolite,
that will terminate
the drug effect,
and that is equivalent
to elimination
via metabolism.
The drug needs to
be excreted and this
is by far most frequently
via the kidney.
By far.
In the kidney,
through the kidney,
inactive metabolites
or unchanged drug
may pass through
or active metabolites
and then be excreted
via the urine.
Let's begin with
absorption. The movement
of substances
across physiologic
barriers into the
central circulation and
of course we're talking
about the drugs.
There are a
number of ways to
pass through
physiologic barriers.
Passive diffusion
through the membrane,
the lipophilic
membrane, is the most
frequent method
of diffusion, of
passage through the
physiologic barriers.
Other mechanisms that
many drugs may be
using are through
transporters. So we see all
these various types
of transporters listed
here. I won't go into
it now because I'll
be talking about that
a little bit later.
Another way is for
molecules that are
dissolved in the plasma,
small molecules, can
pass between cells,
paracellular transport,
by solvent drag.
So first let's
talk about passive
diffusion of the
lipid-soluble
drugs across
cell membranes.
The key driver is
the concentration
gradient. The
drug will pass
down an area of
high concentration
to an area of low
concentration.
When the number of
molecules on one side
equals the number
of molecules on the
other side, It will be
in a dynamic equilibrium,
and there will be
no net movement.
The rate, in
pharmacokinetics, we're
talking about rate,
and we will also talk
about the extent,
how much, how fast
and how much the
drug molecules move.
So the rate and
extent of the flow of
the drug molecules
are influenced by
the magnitude of
the concentration
gradient across the
membrane. The greater
the gradient, the
faster the rate.
The lipid water
partition coefficient
of the drug will
determine its ability
to get through
this lipid layer.
The membrane surface
area of the drug,
so how much of the
membrane is available
for passage? Is
it a large amount
or is it just
maybe, let's use the
other side, just
maybe a small amount?
the permeability of the
membrane and
the thickness.
If it's a thick
membrane, let's make a
thick membrane, versus
a thin membrane, it
will take longer to
pass through the thick
membrane than thin
membrane. So all kinds
of different features
of the membrane
determine the rate and
extent of the flow.
This is the basic
concept that describes
the movement of drug
across the membrane,
across the physiologic
barrier. You do not
need to memorize
this equation, this
relationship, but you
should recognize, This is
the takeaway, that
diffusion across the lipid
bilayer of cell
membranes depends on the
drug's lipid water
partition coefficient.
And that is going
to determine how
readily the drug
enters the lipid
membrane from the
aqueous medium.
It's related to
the concentration
gradient, the area, the
permeability, and
the thickness.
of the drug and
the membrane.
Weak acids and weak
bases, the Henderson
-Hasselbalch equation
and ion trapping.
For weak acids and
weak bases, the pKa
of the drug and the
pH of the medium
determine the ratio
of molecules in
the charged or
ionized form compared
to the uncharged and
non-ionized form.
Here is the key.
The uncharged, non
-ionized form is the more
lipid-soluble form of
the drug. So a weak
acid and weak bases
dissociate in fluid.
They dissociate to
an uncharged form and
a charged form. It
is the uncharged form
that will pass
through the membranes.
Now, a greater
fraction of the weak
acid will be in the
lipid-soluble form
in the more acidic
medium, where the
pH is lower than
the pKa of the drug.
A greater fraction
of the weak base
will be in the lipid
-soluble B form, you
notice there's no
proton on there,
in a more alkaline
medium where the pH
is greater than the
pKa of the drug.
I'm sure you're familiar
with the Henderson
-Hasselbalch equation.
What we're looking at
in pharmacology is the
ratio of the unprotonated
form to the protonated
form. How much
of the drug, of a weak
acid or weak base,
is going to pass through
the lipid membrane?
We know the pH.
pH is very in the
body. We think about
plasma as 7.4, plasma
and interstitial
fluids as 7.4, so
we know the pH,
and we know the
pKa of the drug, so
that leaves the ratio
to be determined.
To repeat,
the lower the pH
relative to the
pKa, the greater
will be the fraction
of drug in the
protonated form.
Weak acids are
not ionized when
they're protonated
and that's indicated
by A for acid
and H for proton.
Weak bases are
ionized when they are
protonated. B for
base and H for proton.
Key concept.
Here it is illustrated.
We have our
lipid bilayer.
We have our different
body compartments.
The non-ionized
form of the, sorry,
the ionized form of
the acid indicated
located by A- will
not pass through.
The HA form will
pass through.
Here it is on
the other side,
dissociating
dependent on the
pKa and the pH
of the fluid in
the body
compartment it's in.
Weak base,
the protonated form
will not pass through.
The non-protonated
B form will
pass through and
same concept,
just the weak
base this time.
This figure here
at the top shows
the pKa right here
in the middle.
When the pH equals
the pKa then And the
both forms, the
ionized and non-ionized
forms, are in equal
concentration.
Let's say the pKa
of the weak acid is
right here. It doesn't
have to be right
here. Let's say it's
right here. Then we
have an increasing
amount of the ionized
form as we move up.
An increasing amount
of the non-ionized
form as we move down.
But very few areas
in the body have a pH
so low. The one
exception is the stomach.
Let's say we have a weak
base of, let's say here.
then the majority
of it will be in the
ionized form BH
plus but as the pH
increases the majority
will be in the B
non-ionized form but
there the pH is in
this area are
incompatible with life.
To repeat non-ionized
molecules diffuse
used readily across
the membrane.
So what do we do
with this information
in terms of the
clinical utilization
of it? It's all
very interesting.
It's called ion
trapping. Trapping
of the ionized
form in a fluid
for the purpose, usually,
of increasing the rate of
excretion of a
toxic compound.
We can also talk
about it in terms of
how much drug is
going to be excreted
in a particular pH
of urine versus how
much will stay
in. That can be
therapeutically important,
but not commonly.
Starting on the
left-hand side.
Blood pH, 7.4.
A drug in concentration
of one micromolar
in the non-protonated
form. This is a weak
base we're talking
about in this example.
and the pH with this
example which I took
from the basic and clinical
pharmacology review
book it is a weight
base with a pK of 7.0
the tendency
is to be in the
non-ionized non
-protonated form
and we still of course
get a certain amount
in the protonated form
so between the two
we have one micromole
and the non-protonated
0.4 micromole and the
protonated and here's
the total it is one
drug after all the non
-protonated form readily
crosses the membrane
you see here it can
cross both directions.
The pH of the urine,
however, is 6.0 in
this example, which
is pretty common.
Urine tends to be acidic.
And we see this
thicker arrow
pointing towards
the protonated form.
Lower pH, more of
the molecule of this
weak base will be in
the protonated form.
So, we still have
1 micromole of
the non-protonated,
but we have 11
micromoles of the
protonated form.
Therefore, we
have a greater
amount that's
not passing back
through, indicated
by this arrow.
And it will
pass out through
the urine and
be excreted.
It's a basic idea
of ion trapping.
This is actually
a strategy used
most frequently for
salicylate toxicity.
And salicylate
is a weak acid.
So the whole
idea then would
be to increase
urine pH to 7 or
8, as high as
we can get it,
so that we can trap
the salicylate in the
urine and excrete it
at a greater rate.
Let's talk about
transporters now.
That's another way for
drugs to pass through
physiologic barriers.
Not all drugs have
the lipid solubility
to be able to actually
pass through the
bilayer. So there are
transporters. And these
transporters, of course,
are present because our
natural body processes
require them, but the
drugs use them also.
Now,
membrane transporters
are selective,
so a drug must
actually need to be a
substrate of the
transporter in order
for it to pass through
the transporter.
and it is selective
for a specific
conformational
structure of the
drug. That's
basically what we're
talking about,
being a substrate.
They are saturable
because they are
doors. They are
doors across the
membrane and if
they're busy, then
other drugs can't
pass through them.
their expression can be
increased or decreased
just like metabolic
enzymes they are
subject to competitive
inhibition as i said before
if they are busy
another substrate is not
going to be able to
pass through it because
it's busy it's saturated
all of them saturated
It's not just one
transporter, there are
probably hundreds of
thousands, at least.
It is also subject
to non-competitive
inhibition. In other
words, a drug that
binds to an allosteric
site can change
the conformation of
the transporter such
that the substrate
is unable to bind.
Excuse me, I pushed
the wrong button.
Genetic variance.
Well we all have our
certain appearances
based on our genes
and the transporters
can be subject
to mutations that
increase or decrease
their effects.
There is a potential
for adverse effects
and drug interactions
based on the fact
that they can be
induced, down-regulated,
competitive inhibition,
non-competitive
inhibition, and
genetic variants.
This figure
here shows that
transporters really
are everywhere.
There are two major
families, the SLC
or solute carrier
family. These are
the carrier proteins,
the channels,
secondary active
transporters.
The carrier proteins
and channels just allow
passive diffusion,
facilitative diffusion
and passive diffusion,
down the concentration
gradient without the
requirement of energy.
The drug molecule just
moves through until
the concentrations on
both sides are equal.
And then it
would be no net
movement, a dynamic
equilibrium.
And I'm writing this
again so you
don't forget.
Secondary active
transporters are the type
where two or more
substances will use that
same transporter. One
substance, frequently
sodium, moves down its
concentration gradient,
in this case
electrochemical gradient,
that supplies the
energy for the
movement of
another substance.
And the ABC
superfamily, ATP.
All you have to really
remember is AATP.
AATP. ATP
requires energy.
I mean, it
supplies energy.
for primary
active transport
against the
concentration gradient.
The ATPase is the
enzyme that catalyzes
ATP hydrolysis supplying
the energy. The
ABC superfamily
of primary active
transporters provide active
efflux of xenobiotics,
products that we
put into our body
that are not natural
to the body and get
pushed back against
the concentration
gradient. A typical
example would be the
intestine, where the
drug goes into the
epithelial cells
and gets pushed back
into the lumen. It
should go like this.
And the liver.
There are active
transporters for biliary
excretion to push them
out of the hepatocytes
into the biliary
system. for excretion.
Kidney, same thing. Blood
-brain barrier,
and on and on.
Point out this
little figure
here. This is,
I believe, to
represent the
placental barrier,
but I could be
wrong about that.
Maybe you can tell.
Here we have figures
of the various types of
transporters. We have
carrier protein and
facilitated transport
channel, all these
various solute carrier
types of transporters for
passive transport,
facilitated transport.
And our active
transporters, this is called
a sodium potassium
ATPase, and that is
the motor that powers
active transport.
Here's our ATP,
goes to ADP,
releases that
phosphate with energy.
This is an example
of ion channels,
sodium ATPase
again, sodium
potassium ATPase
supplying the power,
sodium then goes down
the concentration
gradient and that
supplies the energy
for the movement,
in this case of
bicarbonate, and in
this case of an active,
sorry, this is an
antipower, it goes the
different direction,
the opposite
direction. And this is
some other molecule.
Passive transport,
secondary active
transport, and primary
active transport.
The p-glycoprotein
is one of
the most well
-studied ATPases.
It is, this is a
picture of it. You don't
have to memorize
what it looks like.
You don't have to
recreate that. What you
do need to know is
that P-glycoprotein
is an ATP-dependent
pump, active efflux
of drugs from the
cell. We'll be talking
about this over and
over and over and
over because it
is essential for
understanding certain
drug-drug interactions.
P-glycoprotein is located
on the apical side
of plasma membranes
right next to lumens.
It is expressed in
intestine, liver,
kidney, brain capillaries,
placenta, other
tissues. It is
expressed on tumor
cells and confers
multi-drug resistance.
And there are certain
efflux transporters
on bacteria that pump
our antibiotics out.
A little bit of a review.
The practice
questions give more
interesting questions
for application
of the knowledge.
This is just a
check your knowledge
review, and I
recommend that you
pause the computer,
answer them in
your own words from
your own memory,
and then after you
try, look it
up, and then try
answering from your
own memory again.
So please pause
if you wish.
And coming back now,
what physicochemical
property determines the
ability of a drug to
passively diffuse
through lipid membranes?
By what mechanism
can a hydrophilic
drug cross
physiologic barriers?
For drugs that
are weak acids and
weak bases, why
is the pH of a
biologic fluid
clinically important?
And here are the answers.
The lipid water
coefficient of a
drug, which is the
ratio of the drug
in the lipid and
the aqueous phases,
determines how
readily the drug
molecule moves across
lipid membranes.
Lipid-soluble
drugs passively
diffuse through the lipid
membranes, which
are not saturable.
The rate of transfer, I'm
always talking
about rates,
across the membranes
from an area
of higher
concentration to lower
concentration is
directly proportional
to the lipid
water coefficient.
A hydrophilic drug
can cross physiologic
barriers via
transport proteins.
Passive diffusion or
facilitated transport
down the concentration
gradient.
Or energy using
active transport.
That would be
secondary and primary.
Transporters are
saturable. When all the
transporters are occupied,
then nothing else
can get through until
they are unoccupied.
They are at their
maximum rate of transfer.
Weak acids and weak
bases either gain or
lose electrical charge
-bearing protons, depending
on their pKa and the
pH of the medium.
only the uncharged
form of the drug will
passively diffuse across
the lipid bilayer while
the charged form does
not this is called
ion ion trapping
manipulation of urine ph may
be appropriate for
increasing the rate of
excretion by ion
trapping of certain drugs
such as toxic concentrations
of salicylates.
Okay, so how do we
introduce the drug
into the body? Looking
at this figure,
it's easy to see
that basically by any
method, any *******
and injection into
everywhere,
basically.
Skin, veins,
arteries,
spine,
ventricles.
Selection of the
root is determined by
the properties of the
drug and therapeutic
objectives. What
is the goal of
therapy? How quickly
does the drug need
to be on board in
therapeutic levels.
I'm not going to
go through every
single route of
administration.
I have a table at
the end of this
PowerPoint with the
benefits and disadvantages
of all of the
various routes of
administration. You
do need to know it.
need to know this
is medicine. This is
how you are going
to administer drugs
to your patient. So
this is straightforward,
and you can look
through that
on your own. You do
need to learn it.
This is a quick
overview. enteral roots
either so going through
the mouth basically
or an enteral tube
or at the other
end rectally going into
the gut now sublingual
and buckle go into
the mouth this
is tongue under the
tongue this is between
the gum and cheek
but they pass through
the mucous membranes
of the mouth into
the venous drainage
of the oral cavity.
The upper small
intestine, upper
small intestine, is
the major site of
oral drug absorption
because the
intestine is made for
absorption. That's
its job. It's an
absorptive organ.
The stomach is
not an absorptive
organ. It is a
digestive organ.
Parenteral, so drugs
that are injected.
I've indicated all the
various routes
of injection.
Topical, we think
of topical as
application for
local effect.
Skin comes to mind
readily, eyes, ears.
Lungs,
people who take
inhalers for
lung disease.
we're applying the
drug directly
to lung tissue.
Gut, if the drug
is not absorbed and
stays in the gut,
it can actually
be used topically
for gut problems.
And transdermal, this
is transmucosal here,
transdermal is
topical, however it's
intended to pass
through the skin
layers for systemic
circulation.
This little figure
shows where the
needle is injected
for various
parenteral roots
through the skin.
So that's all I'm
going to say about
absorption and
administration, or I
should say routes
of administration,
so please do learn
that on your own.
So distribution
is the process by
which a drug
reversibly leaves the
bloodstream
and enters the
interstitial and
intracellular fluids.
Moving through the
body, two targets.
First pass effect,
bioavailability, and
extent of distribution.
The first pass
effect is merely how
much of the drug that's
taken ****** will
pass through the gut
into the portal
circulation, pass through
the liver and be
metabolized within the
liver. So first pass
effect is basically
the inactivation by
drug metabolism and
a certain percent will
then be distributed
however much manages
to get through
that process to the
systemic circulation.
So the first pass
effect just to
reiterate so you won't
be confused, is about
the inactivation by
drug metabolizing.
Enzymes of oral
drugs, because they
pass through the
liver first before
going into the
systemic circulation.
Now bioavailability
is the amount
that actually
passes through and
gets to the systemic
circulation.
so it is the fraction
of the dose of the
active drug that
reaches the systemic
circulation so a drug
that is taken ******
and is completely
metabolized through by
the liver on the first
pass is not a useful
drug because very
little of it will
get to the systemic
circulation So, all
drugs that are oral
must have some degree
of bioavailability in
order to be useful.
the rate and extent of
distribution through
the body is determined
by for the i don't
know how many times
now 25th time or
something the physical
physical chemical
properties of the
drug and the patient's
physiologic factors is
the patient young and
healthy? Does the
patient have adequate
cardiac output, adequate
regional blood flow?
How is the capillary
permeability? That's
how drugs get into
interstitial spaces.
And what is the volume
of this patient,
the tissue volume?
How large are
they? How much muscle
mass do they have?
How much fat mass
do they have, etc.
Now redistribution,
that's certainly
an important concept
in distribution.
We'll talk about
redistribution.
This is so boards
relevant. So
what is it? What
we're talking
about is one dose
of a highly lipid
soluble drug. So
what kind of drug
is that? Let's
say an anesthetic.
That's when we
talk about it most
frequently. So we're
talking about one
dose of an anesthetic.
We might be
talking about an
anti-seizure drug.
So we see on this figure,
the peak is right here.
So if it's an oral
drug, it's going to
be a lag time. But
let's talk about an
IV drug. It's administered
IV, gets right
away into the
bloodstream, and it will
be carried
through the body
to the highly
perfused organs.
So VRG stands for
vessel-rich group.
And what is the
vessel-rich group that
we're concerned with
with an anesthetic?
The brain, CNS, brain,
and spinal cord.
All right, this
one dose of
drug travels to the brain
and because the
brain tissue has no
molecules in it at
that moment and the
concentration in blood
is high, the drug will
move down its
concentration gradient into
the CNS tissues and
produce its effects.
And as the drug
does that and
moves through
the body, the
concentration in
drug now decreases.
At the same time, the
vessel-rich group,
including the CNS, is
taking up the drug.
So the concentration
increases in the vessel
-rich group, decreases
in the bloodstream,
there's only a certain
amount that has to go
around to everywhere,
produces its effect.
And as the
bloodstream, as
the drug in
blood is reduced,
you see it's even
going into the
skeletal muscles
here, but much
more slowly because
they're less
perfused than the
vessel-rich group.
Now the drug is
moving out of the CNS
tissues back into
the blood because the
concentration gradient
in the blood is lower.
Okay,
and drug moves to
the other tissues
based on the level
or perfusion. So the
point is, with
redistribution, the drug
produces its CNS
effect very rapidly.
And with the one dose,
as the concentration
in plasma decreases,
the CNS effect decreases,
decreased CNS effect.
This phenomenon
occurs primarily
when one dose
of highly lipid
-soluble drug
acting on the brain
and spinal cord is
administered rapidly
by intravenous injection
or by inhalation.
Many anesthetics,
well, a few
anesthetics are
by inhalation.
The drug rapidly
distributes to the CNS,
moves down the
concentration gradient into
the CNS tissues, and
produces its effect.
The drug then moves
back into the blood
as it is taken up
by the less vascular
tissues, which, and
here's the key point,
terminates the
CNS effect.
But, IV administration
of drug moves to
CNS, produces its
effect, then it quickly
terminates the CNS
effect as it moves
out of the CNS
tissue back into the
bloodstream. Now,
this is not related to
the drug moving out
of the body, being
excreted by the
body. It's just the
redistribution into
the peripheral tissues.
That's the concept.
Termination of
CNS effect of
this highly lipid
-soluble drug.
One dose by
redistribution
to the peripheral
tissues.
That's it.
Distribution across
the placenta. The fetus
is to some extent
exposed to all drugs,
or nearly all drugs,
taken by the mother.
Placental transfer
of drugs across the
placenta may cause
anomalies in the developing
fetus. So the general
determinants of
drugs that can produce
important levels
in the fetus's
bloodstream, systemic
circulation, are the
lipid solubility of the
drug. If it's lipid
-soluble, it can, as
you know, can cross
physiologic membranes.
If the drug is
highly protein-bound,
then there is a
lower amount of free
drug that can
cross the lipid
membranes. But it
could still be enough.
Fetal plasma is
slightly more acidic
than the mother,
so thinking
about ion-trapping
of basic drugs.
P-glycoprotein and other
export transporters
are part of that blood
placenta barrier.
So they function
to limit the fetal
exposure of certain
drugs. Drugs that
are substrates of
poor P-glycoprotein.
Now drug reservoirs.
I've mentioned this
a few times by now.
Drug reservoirs
and other, think
about storage
sites, storage.
Reversible binding,
and that's how
these are. The
drugs are 99.999999%
reversible binding
to the inert plasma
proteins and inert
tissue macromolecules
tends to sequester
the drug in those
compartments. So
what does that mean?
Drugs on inert
molecules are not free.
They are not free
to be metabolized.
to be excreted. They
are not free to
travel to their
site of action or
anywhere else. They
are riding around
on the albumin bus.
Albumin is the major
plasma protein that
we're thinking about
when it comes to
sequestering of drugs
on plasma proteins.
Drugs that bind to tissue
macromolecules stay
in the tissues.
Now this is
reversible, don't
forget, reversible
binding.
So the drugs can be on
and off and on and off.
And the extent
depends on their
affinity for those
plasma proteins
and the concentration
of drug.
Looking at our plasma
protein concept here,
we have our drug protein
complex and free drug.
This is in dynamic
equilibrium at
steady state.
So steady state
occurs with continuous
dosing. Either it's an
IV dose that's going
in by continuous
infusion or it's dosed
by any route of
administration that goes in
at a frequency, at
a regular frequency.
So that's what we
mean by continuous
dosing. And it
gets to the point
where there is
dynamic equilibrium.
Here's our free
drug molecules in
plasma in this figure,
and you can see
they pass through the
spaces and capillaries
and they move
into the tissues.
The bound drug does not.
That's the basic idea.
We'll talk more about
that in a future lecture.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Okay, so some of
the features of drug
binding to these inert
molecules, meaning
they don't have a
regulatory effect,
they're important,
but they don't cause,
when they're, they
don't have, they're
not activated and
producing some
biologic effect as on
molecules, on cells.
drug binding is non
-selective so that
means a wide variety
of different chemical
structures can
be bound to the
plasma protein it's
variable saturable
there are only just
so many molecules of
albumin floating
around in the blood it
is non-linear meaning
it's saturable
and it is reversible.
So on and off
and on and off
in a dynamic equilibrium.
The fraction bound is
determined by how much
drug there is. So the
drug concentration.
What is the affinity
of that plasma protein
for the drug? If
it has no affinity,
it won't bind the
drug. or it might have
high affinity and
bind the drug tightly,
but it's usually
somewhere in the middle.
And albumin has a
number of binding sites.
It could be
binding a number of
different molecules
at the same time.
So if there are
a large number,
then it's got a big
capacity to bind
drugs. If there's
a small number
available, then a
smaller capacity.
Competition and
disease related factors
can determine the
extent of drug binding.
So here's a check
your knowledge
and perhaps you
would like to
pause the video
and try and answer
these on your own.
So you may pause now.
and welcome back. I hope
you gave this
some thought.
Oral drugs are
absorbed mainly
from what part
of the intestine?
What is the clinical
significance of the
phenomenon of redistribution
when applied to
highly lipophilic drugs
such as anesthetics?
What is the concern
about drugs that
can cross the blood
placenta barrier?
And what is the
clinical relevance
of drug binding to plasma
proteins and tissue
macromolecules.
Drugs are absorbed
mainly from the
upper small intestine,
which has a very
large surface
area for absorbing
nutrients and drugs,
because of villi along
the length of the
small intestine.
The redistribution
refers to a drug that
will go immediately
to the CNS, produce
the CNS effect,
and as the drug is
redistributed to the
peripheral tissue,
the plasma concentration
of the drug is
reduced and the CNS
effect is diminished.
Drugs able to cross the
blood placenta barrier
can lead to fetal
exposure of the drug.
Practitioners need to
know what drugs are
safe, what drugs are
toxic to the fetus, and
at which stages of the
pregnancy. This is a
must-know that we will
talk about as we go
through these various
drug classes later on.
Plasma proteins
and tissue
macromolecules
are inert. They do
not regulate
cellular actions.
Drugs reversibly bound
to plasma proteins
or tissue macromolecules
are sequestered.
They're not free
to be metabolized,
excreted, or reach
the site of action.
As the concentration
of free drug decreases
due to elimination,
drug molecules
dissociate, which
maintains the free drug
concentration at a
constant fraction.
And in summary, this
is a little mind
map of the
pharmacokinetic processes.
The physicochemical
characteristics of
a drug determine its
ability to withstand
digestive fluids
and enzymes and be
absorbed from the
GI tract, cross
physiologic barriers,
survive metabolic
processes. distribute
to the site of action
in therapeutic
concentrations and exit
the site of action
and be eliminated.
Drugs move along
their concentration
gradients by passive
diffusion across the
lipid bilayer of
cell membranes or by
carrier or channel
-mediated transport.
Drugs may also be
pumped out by energy
-dependent active
transport. very large
or lipid-insoluble
drugs may enter or exit
cells by endocytosis
or pinocytosis,
which I didn't actually
mention before.
This applies to
so few drugs.
The rate and extent of
flow of drug molecules
are influenced by
the magnitude of a
concentration gradient
across the membrane, lipid
solubility, that is
to say lipid water
partition coefficient,
membrane surface area,
thickness, and
permeability. Weak acids and
weak bases are present
in solution as both a
non-ionized and ionized
species. The non
-ionized molecules usually
are more lipid soluble
and can diffuse
readily across the cell
membrane, whereas the
ionized molecules usually
are less able to
********* the lipid
membrane because of their
low lipid solubility.
Transmembrane
distribution is
determined by the
drugs pKa and the
pH gradient across
the membrane.
Different routes
of administration
are used in clinical
medicine for
various reasons,
such as convenience,
rapid onset of
action, maximizing
concentration at
the site of action,
avoiding first
-pass effect,
and minimizing
adverse effects.
The rate and extent
of drug distribution
are determined by
the physico-chemical
properties of the drug and
the physiologic factors
of cardiac output,
regional blood flow,
capillary permeability,
and tissue volume.
Extensive binding to
inert proteins and
other macromolecules
may slow the rate at
which a drug reaches
the site of action
and may prolong the
duration of action as
the drugs are sequestered
in the tissues.
These are the tables
I mentioned before.
It tells you the
root, the absorption
pattern, what
they're useful
for, and potential
disadvantages.
There are lots of
roots. Most of this is
intuitive. you probably
know it already,
but you do need to know
it. As a physician,
it's so so important
to be able to
select the right route
of administration.
And that concludes
part one of our
pharmacokinetics
ADME, administration,
distribution, metabolism,
and excretion.